حي البشناق في ميتروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو
يكتب التجار على واجهات محلهم بلغتين
الالمانيه والصربيه بعضهم يختار
الانجليزيه وجميعهم يريدون زبائن من كلا
المجتمعين المحليين
سكنت عائلته هنا منذ اكثر من 100 عام كما
يقول ويملك هذا المقهى الصغير
وكل ما نريده هو السلام لا اكثر السياسيون
هم المشكله وسنكون في حال افضل لو تركتنا
الولايات المتحده والغرب وشاننا
على بعد امتار يدير نور الدين محل البسه
يؤكد الالباني الذي ولد في الحي احترامه
لجيرانه السرب لكن نظرته الى العالم
مختلفه عنهم الى حد بعيد
التي ينصبونها احيانا
لتعليمات صربيا لقد ادت التوترات الاخيره
الى تراجع الحركه التجاريه كثيره في هذا
الشارع
المحليه المتنافسنا يقول الاهالي ان
الاموال مخصصه للتسابق الى شراء العقارات
على حساب صيانه البنا التحتيه
صحيح انهم في عين عاصفه التوترات لكنهم
معفونه من دفع الضرائب وفواتير الطاقه
مقابل بقائهم الحي صغير وسكانه بضعه الاف
ولكن من خلاله يمكن رؤيته كتفه بمخاوفها
واعمالها معا فهنا قد يتجسد التعايش
والقبول ومن هنا قد تشتعل العداوات
العرقيه مجددا محمد المدهون الجزيره من
بلده ميتروفيتسا شماليه كسب